Congress my name welcome back I'm crying
on the other side because this game was
just made for YouTube all right let's
play this one all right finally we can
play something go not dead and if you
dead try again that's just [ __ ]
awesome English isn't it son that the
English you learn in school no dead I'm
much better than that I don't care
that's a [ __ ] excuse - I don't care
why are you scared of stairs you [ __ ]
because you pushed me down yeah oh no I
don't have any hard hi okay I made it
pretty well that wasn't that difficult
alright let's play I don't care see how
much I care I'm still going strong still
going strong ah you're just staring a
background not doing [ __ ] good at this
game there's thing all right Robert well
yeah son
what no what the hell you did what
the son is that one of your [ __ ]
friends go and say whoa dad carries -
dad
you [ __ ] what what what's happened
dad can you please take away this head
for me it's disgusting I don't care wait
what is this hold I hear something what
is this my sister there
love destroy what hold what I'm going
down here dad I'm scared and I'm can
keep the head there keep dad you like
that son
I punch you I punish you for being so
stupid that's right
I punch you dad place is disgusting I
don't care if it's disgusting slap you I
slap you I slap you
I slap you for disrespecting me that's
what you get I'll keep slapping you on
the purse oh you call the cops on me
this is what you get go away shut up
shut up I'm sorry I don't know there's
something wrong with me normal right
have I shave Ziegfeld Danish thanks for
playing
all right son this is your chance to
redeem yourself and redeem your [ __ ]
let's do this for Lady Gaga shut up I'm
doing a [ __ ] I don't even know at our
age without it what now now I did ah
stupid son you keep [ __ ] everything
up don't you
I'm sorry are you still with me son
Dylan I'm I think a red light by the
[ __ ] are you are you drunk again turn on
shut happen you enjoy the [ __ ]
[Music]
harness [ __ ] ah you're just annoying
that's your mother what a melon sure it
sounds awesome
let's try another character this total
artists I don't know I don't know why I
picked Indiana Jones guy he's kind of
gay
the black guy the card afro-american I
am so sorry dad Scott oh oh no oh no
wait I'm gonna [ __ ] eat that [ __ ]
like a bus now what that's it this
actually lag in my computer
okay that was racist that was highly
racist my grandma I can make this cha
cha
I made it didn't I yes but you unmake
this one yes a well [ __ ] ah oh oh this
looks good
how are you in this position ya gotta be
my cat father
can you sing scary now I can't I steady
as we go steady we go I don't care about
careful
I am [ __ ] I know we're still alive I
don't care about you I'm out of here
stupid son all right front flip double
yes I made it like like Tehran I'm sorry
about ours
alright Harbor bike no I don't want to
do any tests butcher night now we play
that one mechanical bull ride did we
play this Oh a mechanical bull ride
lovely oh let's do it one more time no
gotta grab that set by the horns Oh Oh
take me here take me here whoa whoa this
is a ride I love it I [ __ ] love it oh
yes oh oh whoa chill do it
that was quite the experience still
strong
Hey what are you doing with my arms try
this again
grab that [ __ ] oh now on our last man
get damage difficulty just like your
mother
all right stings done five seconds come
on now I know you're a feisty one aren't
you oh oh no no gotta make it you gotta
make it
Oh grab it by the [ __ ] grab it by the
[ __ ] humping oh yes hump it oh yes
yes yes ah you like that don't you you
little [ __ ]
okay what the hell is going on this is
awesome
oh yes oh no no no no like a boss I want
to try him one more time
oh no that's the head can't lose the
head drop it alright new jump ah ah [ __ ]
it one my well more time we gonna
celebrate celebrate and dance so try one
more time music's got me feeling to pray
Superman version harp owns everybody
thank know I'll buy that Hank I strike
it'd kill cadaver chest lovely
absolutely lovely
hold the children and throw them in
space [ __ ] hey dead your dad is not
here shut up I don't even know what I'm
doing
pump it up there go up there no no no ah
[ __ ] they told me I could be anything so
I became a mass murderer
oh my god glitch parody alright I'll try
this one
what pushed her down what
Mike no c'mon green ropes I've been told
I should play some ropes levels so let's
try this one
lovely position that I okay so you
inject yourself with shift I think yeah
come on come on
shallow abrade good tat come on dudu
come on gotta get to that [ __ ] rope
if last thing I'll do I'm on a [ __ ]
rope I'm on a rope I'm on a rub
everybody oh yeah don't hurt yourself I
don't care am I going down here like a
bass oh no stop da it was all your fault
son sorry Dave so sorry
alright grab it like a boss see you
later sucker I don't care about anything
all right release No ah god damn it's
all your [ __ ] fault isn't it alright
are you planning this I'm out of here
[ __ ] alright alright alright
what the [ __ ] are you doing I don't even
know polish grab the rope
grab the rope like a boss that was not
like a boss grab it
come on come closer dad what are you
doing you look silly shut up I never
look silly
I am [ __ ] your dad I am your dad I
mean what what whatever don't question
me all backslap lack about fashion world
Oh No
right and describe him Howard ever I
don't want I wasn't planning on having
any more children anymore ah God just
date me at oh look at this position o ye
sons of [ __ ] I'm doing this like a BA
our our house no no no cannonbolt all
right I have to end this episode here
I'm sorry it was a little short I have a
busy day going out for the mission
since I have to like 15 George you've
got to come a road today and I'll seen
what happened next episode I try to make
and that's probably kind of fearsome mmm
I scream so much the past episodes you
have no idea if I upload all of the boss
fighting cry of fear I don't know I
scream a lot like a band
[Music]